it looks like for dance cause going back
to the 1980s
and that call of duty 2021 may be a
world war ii game
what does this mean for the future of
war zone and where do battlefield fans
fit into all of this
i'm joined by aaron sampson and guys if
you are enjoying these weekly call of
duty chats
leave a thumbs up and leave comments we
are always down there responding
and we can pick them out for our future
videos alright let's get into
warzone in the 80s
aaron a trailer leaked which you know at
the time of filming can still be found
on youtube people are bravely posting
the unfinished trailer
and we're seeing some funny comments
they showed off
a 80s version of verdansk
complete with an unfinished stadium some
parts from
cold war like the duga array but aaron
and i
we've talked about this before it could
be a positive thing you know
tweaking a map tweaking an existing map
can be a very good thing we've
talked about even a night variant of the
map but the question is
the really big question is how are we
going to go from modern day verdance all
the way back to the 80s
i'm going to spin this over to aaron
who's got some theories on this
alright so the leak that we just
mentioned is the first one that seems
very very official there have been leaks
in the past about going into the
mountains using the dirty bomb maps
there have been audio leaks about the
the plague mode which we think is going
to be an ltm that might transition the
two
but that's a very good question like how
the hell are we gonna get from the
modern verdance map
and go back in time now i'm gonna pitch
a theory here
and again we're just going on rumors and
speculation until things actually happen
and we think things might happen
mid this month so i think we'll know the
answer to this
soon but i'm kind of starting to think
that the nuke event
is maybe not going to happen the way
that anybody thinks it's going to happen
it's been something that's been teased
for a long time
it seems like we might i'm pitching this
theory but we might have to take captain
price's storyline at face value
that he stopped the nuclear weapons
because that's what we saw at the end of
the modern warfare storyline
nukes are stopped like done um i don't
think you know the nuke might not hit
the map
there was recently a splash screen that
showed the zombies and the dam
so that's significant because something
that players have been finding
is weird stuff at the dam um as the
seasons have progressed
for example like one season people
thought they saw a glow under the dam
then this season for absolutely no
reason they added some docks to the dam
so here's my leading theory which is
that zombies have always been tied
together with time travel
um so there's going to be some
catastrophic zombie event it's probably
going to be a limited time mode
and there's i'm just going to guess
there's going to be a portal or
something that's going to open up around
the dam because they keep focusing on
the dam
and we're probably going to take that
portal back to the 80s the interesting
thing about that
if we're doing zombies and time travel
is that that also answers like a very
burning question that we've all had
recently which is
i think despite people being a little
bit disappointed that it seems like and
this is again just a rumor but it seems
like
the next call of duty game is going to
be a world war ii game
how do we get verdance in world war ii
together like how does that even
how does warzone and world war ii ever
come together in any way
shape or form and this is it like
zombies and time travel
that that's that's it because we're not
we're not going to get nuked back to the
80s that's not how nuclear weapons
work you know maybe maybe we'll be like
in plague mode maybe we'll be escaping
the nukes and escape
back into a time portal or something
like that but yeah like
it seems very much like we're getting an
80s map in verdansk so yeah like in
summary
um i'm starting to really doubt the nuke
is gonna happen at all
uh we'll probably like have a zombie
invasion and jump into a giant portal
maybe in the dam
and now we're off in time travel props
to activision because
if you're time traveling now you can go
to any call of duty game
in war zone i don't know it could i'm
hoping it's not just being patched
together as they go along but if they
know what they're doing and they really
they really utilize this the stories uh
in the zombie universe
they can do some cool things and really
bring warzone and zombies
together better than they are now so
that's the aspiration but what's going
on in the map right now
is i don't know if it's from a technical
limitation to the game which is entirely
possible
or just like a lack of somebody like
running the show which is kind of what
it feels like
but the way that the zombie event is
progressing right now is just glacial
but the current map is not showing a
zombie outbreak even though the
percentage indicator did finally rise
and there's things like bombardments
available now at the zombie machine
which seem to indicate you'll be able to
clear areas of zombies
we're still waiting for the zombies
though um so there's a concern between
aspiration
of where we're going in the execution of
what's happening so aaron speaking of
zombies i've been
capping a lot of footage for uh the
evolution videos we make i'm currently
working on
an ak-47 evolution and i have to go back
and play
the older zombies maps every so often
and i love those maps those were the
first maps that i
played i started from world at war the
very first map compared to
the newer zombies maps the older zombies
maps
really just kick your ass like you have
you don't have a health bar like you do
in cold war you have two hits
four if you have juggernog and the
tricky map design of the older treyarch
style really leaves you like cornered a
lot
i was getting cornered and killed and
like ruining my gameplay because i kept
dying
and i was like how did i ever really do
well at this granted i'm going about it
solo but if you don't perk up
and like pack a punch your gun right
away you really don't stand a chance
they they made it so much harder to just
survive which is fair because that was
the point of those games but
i just want you all to be thankful for
the zombies you have today because it's
a lot it was a lot harder back then
all right so that's the inspiration that
we're looking for to come over from
old world at war zombies into war zone
we're just hoping for a glimmer of that
but there's this whole other topic
that's happening right now which is
the world war two vanguard call of duty
game that now
kind of seems like is gonna happen this
year again announcements are coming
soon spring so we don't know a hundred
percent but richie
what does that mean if call of duty goes
back to world war two
it means a lot like there is potential
for fans of world war
ii but it's not what everyone wants it's
it's sort of a big
blanket of fans that are when they hear
world war
ii they're like no i'm out they don't
want to go backwards they don't want to
deal with
older guns older gameplay styles world
war
ii theme at all tons of people just say
no to a world war ii game
and i get it i was sort of on that train
aaron you and i have discussed
my my history of call of duty i stopped
a little after ghosts i didn't play
advanced warfare infinite warfare bloc
black ops three because of all the the
gameplay style the loot boxes there was
a lot
that just had me out but when i heard
that the next game was going to be a
boots on the ground game i was like cool
whatever it is i'm in
it was world war ii from 2017. i was
like great
okay i it's i was confused but i was
like all right i'll pick it up
you know i just got the job at gamespot
actually so we were starting to cover it
and i fell in love with it like i gave
it a chance and i think it was the most
refined world war ii experience
i've played and i've gone back and
played call of duty one two three
world that war was cool um but world war
ii in 2017 was was a personal favorite
of mine
we had a comment here from darth maul on
that i'm i'm hoping it's the actual
darth maul who who plays video games in
real life
i think the problem is genre fatigue and
i don't know like i don't know if
everybody remembers but anybody in a
certain age demographic remembers that
there was 10 years
where everything was world war ii like
the saving private ryan era
every game was world war ii every game
went back to world war ii and after like
a decade of that people were just
sick of world war ii it was then like
maybe i don't know like seven or eight
years where everything was like going
super future and then everybody got
super sick of that and then
you know battlefield came back and said
they were going back to the world wars
and people got really excited but that
whole time it was like no don't you
remember you guys were all sick of world
war
ii like 10 years ago so you know i think
i think everybody got that like little
taste of world war ii again just like
for old times sake and then they were
like oh yeah we're totally sick of that
and we forgot about that
it feels like a mistake going back to
world war ii again and you
we're we're i think we're on the present
again i really think people just want to
go back to
battlefield 3 style games right i
i agree like as much as i loved world
war ii i just spewed my guts out over it
i think like as a business move
it might not be the smartest thing i
mean i'm gonna play it because
if that's true i i want to give it a
shot i loved world war ii and i really
think more
people should have given world war two
another chance especially i mean for the
for the multiplayer sure but for the
campaign it was such a good story
there are always stories coming out of
world war
ii like sure they take some creative
liberties but that story was so good i
just finished playing it
replaying it and i was just amazed it
felt like you know you're playing
band of brothers but you know as we
always say aaron the bread and butter of
a call of duty game
the legs is the multiplayer you don't
have a good multiplayer you don't have a
big enough uh
player base then you're tanked that's
why they it doesn't always work out
every year
um but i would say give it a shot i'm
hopeful but another window is opening up
for battlefield fans this is where they
can strike if if battlefield
6 takes place in the rumored 2030 era
then you know we might get these uh more
fans leaning towards
that game this year and moving away from
call of duty it can mean
a huge swing in the player base of all
of this
that's a really excellent point richie
and this is something we've talked about
a lot on this show
which is there's two different audiences
there's the people who love the classic
call of duty game and there's the people
who came into call of duty because it
wasn't classic and those are your modern
warfare fans
and they're looking for the next like
near will the next present or near
future shooter the rumors on battlefield
right now
and again i want to make it really clear
that that we don't know yet these
announcements
are yet to come but the most recent leak
was
it'll be set in the 2030s it features
drones robots
and multiplayer which is battlefield 3
on steroids
now we hear a lot of marketing jargon
like this before games come out and part
of our job is to cut through that so i
don't want to like
make you believe any of this if
battlefield is a near future title
and doesn't go into wall running and the
things that people really just kind of
got sick of
if it's near future with near future
tech you know like let's be honest
battlefield has always had near future
tech i mean hell even like the
battlefields that went back to world
wars have like uav pigeons that's not a
thing
i really think that if call of duty goes
world war ii and battlefield goes near
future
say goodbye to modern warfare fans for a
couple years they're not going to come
back until
call of duty has another near future
game
the other big thing up in the air would
just be if battlefield does a battle
royale again and if it's stuck behind a
paywall like it was last time which
totally killed it
because let's be honest like regardless
of what battlefield does i think warzone
is still the best
it's still the best battle royale for
for that audience
so aaron and i love to discuss call of
duty for better or worse
we have a small section here that's for
better we've got a lot of positive stuff
that recently launched including
sanatorium at night
it comes to outbreak and i played it
it's cool
i'm enjoying outbreak so much so if we
can get a new environment or make more
come to the night time i would love that
i'm really enjoying it and i still
overall just love outbreak
and next we've got more good news from
the modern warfare store
erin what's up with the separation here
yeah it's really weird we fired up
modern warfare last week one of people's
big complaints was that they were being
asked to buy a lot of cold war stuff in
the modern warfare store
and as of the last time i checked they
actually seemed to have separated the
stores i was only seeing modern warfare
stuff in there
so that's nice like you're not being
asked to buy things from a game that you
don't own
the other thing that they did was they
stealth added three maps granted their
smaller maps but
they added three maps to modern warfare
our last little bit of good news here is
that cold war is introducing blueprint
mixing
so this is great it's just like modern
warfare where you can take any blueprint
you have
of a specific gun and mix and match
parts of it to make a frankenstein
ugly looking gun or a really sleek
looking gun you can just have fun with
it
that's that sort of customization that
aaron and i love from
modern warfare 2019 and i'm surprised it
wasn't added earlier but it's here now
so that's
great news last but not least of course
we have your guys's user comments
we're always down there reading them and
interacting with you guys so please
continue to leave them
and maybe we'll feature it in the next
episode our first one here comes from
ethan kirby who says who's quoting me
and he says
transit that's a fan favorite map yeah
okay bud
and this was happening a lot on our last
video i'm getting flamed in the comments
and that's okay because just like world
war ii i will defend it
the problem is i might have spoke for
everyone and said oh yeah everyone loves
this map but
i think a lot of people love to hate it
which is probably the issue is when
we're mixing my words
i think more people might have liked mob
of the dead but i like transit it was
way different and it was kind of a pain
in the ass but when you played
you know that made for fun memories when
you're playing with friends
it really took zombies players and made
them feel like a fish out of water
with like the stupid bus and like if you
walk in between certain areas you're
getting scratched alive by those little
monsters
there was fun to be had but yeah okay
maybe it's not everyone's fan favorite
map of black ops 2.
sorry all right our next comment was
probably my favorite of our whole last
video
which was how modern warfare fans and
cold war fans are more alike than you
think
and that the yearly cycle is a true
enemy celeb alert said
the one thing activision really fears is
modern warfare fans and cold war fans
i've got your back brother like this
together
yeah you son of a [ __ ]
everybody gets kind of screwed over by
this yearly cycle in a certain way
uh games aren't supported quite as long
as people would love them to be
maybe that's okay for people who fall
off like a regular call of duty game but
some of the games
modern warfare in particular recently
have just been so fantastic and people
just want to keep going they don't want
to
get off that for the yearly cycle so
here's open modern warfare get some more
support
so we want to bring it back to you guys
in the comments and ask how do you
think warzone will go back to the 1980s
what is the event that you think will
have to happen for this to occur
let us know of your theories in the
comments like the video if you enjoyed
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you